[Music]
what else do we even have to talk about
we could just make it up this is make up
a rumor here madison beer hit that
seven-year-old with her car in the
street she says all right it's just a
kid we still have madison she's still
here wait madison's here she didn't hit
me up before she oh god this bit oh god
what she was mad at me because i [ __ ]
kendall jenner yeah here we go i
dogecath and she didn't reply did you
actually i mean she doesn't follow me or
anything i just like [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna dmr what did you say it's just a
picture of me and then a picture of
french fries and i said just paid seven
dollars for these damn i'm really
surprised she didn't respond to that i
think she's just playing hard to get
though yeah yeah probably elizabeth moss
just texted me
he's got a text from elizabeth warren
[Laughter]
for some reason weirdly wouldn't
surprise me that much if you just got
like a a very weird obscure text from
somebody like that i don't know why it
would just like do you know what i mean
like yeah if cody just got a random text
in the middle of a podcast from like
because he's so la yeah you're saying
dude no it's not even know that joke
yeah i don't even know the joke yeah
everyone's been calling him so la oh
really just can't stop name dropping
this dude they're just like you know
always falling out of his hands and i
actually i was just about to tell a
story good i don't want to tell her
anymore no good go
you know i i told you when dojo guy came
over to my house yeah yeah no i want to
hear the story no that's sick that you
damned her though yeah yeah but she came
to your house but like literally came to
my [ __ ] house but it's sick yeah so
tell the story dude it's not a story
it's literally not a story i just wanted
to say that because it's you seem to be
a fan so i wanted to say that because
i'm also a fan right and i was freaking
out she came over yeah that's it she was
just standing in my kitchen i was
freaking the [ __ ] out i was really drunk
too and i was like just couldn't really
speak yeah that must look so weird to
her she went in your house and you're
like yo dojo yeah no it was it was weird
anyways y'all seen the northmen yeah
that shit's like my movie it's like my
jam way better than marvel you mean that
though oh i do yeah i [ __ ] hate
marvel movies why do you hate them i
think the last marvel movie i saw was
iron man 2. yeah you haven't you even
hit them all then i saw one of the
avengers the very first avengers and
it's like okay that's cool when you're
17. it's not cool now yeah now what's
cool is
alexander skarsgard with his shirt off
yeah yelling like a wolf and like
killing a child that's what marvel
movies are missing with dead children
yeah can we watch the trailer for the
north men at least so i can be in on
this yeah yeah yeah yeah go ahead and
pull up the trailer for like yeah so
this is this is the northmen right here
[Music]
the north men
[Music]
yeah so this guy called that the north
alexander
okay
[Music]
yeah he slays them he slaughters them
because they have a right to the
kingship over him they slaughter the
children the anakin skywalkers them
really yeah what's the deal with the
eggs because why are they counting them
yeah dragon dragon eggs
okay pull up the actual trailer for the
north
yeah that's me they based that character
off me
don't care about any of those people
this was real too what it is i mean
probably right yeah it's a documentary
of how um yeah i forgot his name so the
joke's over
sick joke dude why this is cool
i'm in okay we don't care why this is
cool cody
[Laughter]
why this is cool
that's real right like that's historical
marvel is not real marvel's real dude
green lantern's real um iron man is real
dude ever heard of elon musk
realistically elon is like batman and
tony stark combined which makes him
ultimately yeah even better even better
yeah but anyway this shit's based on my
life of like my ancestors and [ __ ]
gotcha yeah
i'm a [ __ ] viking look at my hair his
hair same thing he was based on me my
abs his abs same thing [ __ ] laura
dern just left me a voicemail what the
[ __ ]
anyway what is this
kim k being a social climber in 2012 the
kardashians were actively banned from
the met gala anna went to a pretty
openly despised the kardashians and no
designer would dress them but all that
changed to 2013 when kanye took a
thor-sized hammer to the doors of
fashion and carried kimmy heavily
pregnant across the threshold demanding
she be acknowledged respected and given
a seat at the table
he infamously cleared out her entire
closet revamping her entire look
taking her from run-of-the-mill reality
star in international fashion it girly
he deployed his fashion photographer
friends to kind of center kim as the new
i'm like
can you [ __ ] do that
what
what it's fine it's good oh you want
some
yeah yeah dude i wanted a drag
is that it is that a cigarette what is
that it's him it's hemp it's hemp yeah i
don't smoke cigs dude what's the point
of smoking a hemp
cigarette yeah it looks cool look how
cool i look no you did look [ __ ] cool
alexander skarsgard pulled out a ciggy
yeah in the northman
and just started smoking a cig after
like killing a child does that even do
anything no
you don't get a buzz from that at all
so then why do you do it
i definitely want one now
oh yeah all right give me one two
coolest book right
all right play that dumb ass [ __ ] you
were just playing
why did i inhale you're supposed to it's
a sick bro blast it
oh yeah right wow that tastes exactly
like a cigarette yeah ghetto put me
under these he's like a cool dj and [ __ ]
so
[Laughter]
that's sick man doesn't he know
elizabeth moss yeah yeah i was chilling
with them and laura dern the other day
that's sick dude
[Laughter]
smoke machine bro yeah it's just this is
it right here yeah can you quiet your
motorcycle we're trying to do something
cool in here like podcasts and smoked
hemp cigarettes yeah dude wow sorry guys
there's a bit of a pause in the action
here as we smoke these cigarettes you
know so stupid why not just smoke real
tobacco are these like just as bad for
you
nah dude these are good for you
you get that cbd buzz yeah it's got that
it's got that [ __ ] uh yeah it's got
cbd in it probably or some [ __ ] i don't
know sick just asked onto these one of
ones
one of one these chairs oh oh i think
you mean your yeah weird like on rogan
there's ashtrays
[Music]
this completely just changed the dynamic
of the whole show yeah it really did we
just start smoking we have to talk about
anything important it's more laid back
you can just watch us just do light up
this is actually not a i love that
you're talking to me with the smoke in
your hand it makes it way better that's
what i'm saying cigarettes are cool as
[ __ ] analogs
what is this this little gamer [ __ ]
right here what is that what they call
this that's digital [ __ ] we're an analog
[ __ ] bro don't hash on the stream
what is this nerd thing right here
if you don't have a sig in your mouth
bro get the [ __ ] down
dude are those ashtrays cool yeah bring
that over here just ask on his wrist
ow put it out on his [ __ ] hand that's
what they would do in the northmen when
i used to deliver pizzas i would always
just listen to like talk radio podcasts
weren't really big at the time one of
the shows was called like the cigar dave
show and it was literally just this old
dude talking about smoking cigars and
drinking whiskey and it [ __ ] ruled
like people would call in and be like
hey man like what type of cigar should i
get or whatever like what whiskey should
i pair that with and he'd be like and
you could hear him like puffing a cigar
the whole time [ __ ] whoa
then just go on so basically that's what
we need to do here yeah this is way
better yeah this really is more relaxed
yeah definitely you want to hand me that
cup did you want ash in here yeah
you